okay so check this out pull up the side
on market watch uh one san francisco
accountant finishes every client
conversation with a discussion
about what a biden administration could
mean for portfolios
okay so very simple at the end of his
meeting with his clients go a little
lower one san francisco account and
finish every meeting with conversation
about an administration
san francisco accountant scott hope had
a client who was planning to stretch the
sale of founders shares in a tech sector
company over three year period
instead the client compressed the
installment sale into one shot
transaction this month meaning
you have 10 million dollars and you're
asking to sell the shares over three
years you get 3.3 million every year why
because you don't want to pay that many
taxes
that much in taxes this year instead the
accountant advised him to do it in one
month why
what excel accelerated this deal the
2020 presidential race
assuming all else was equal that was the
driver of the choice
said hope he's the account a principal
of the accounting firm
why blue right now hope's clients work
between 10 or 20 million dollars will be
taxed on capital gains at a rate of 23.8
percent
if democratic candidate joe biden beats
trump
and democrats retain the house of
representative and flip the state
flip the senate that client could have
potentially been staring
at a 39.6 tax rate
in two out of the installments sales
three years
the compressed transaction then could
have saved the client approximately
three hundred twenty thousand dollars in
taxes
on the six million dollar sale the
seller for sure was motivated and the
buyer had to
wherewithal to pay the full price up
front
so you go down and you read this and
you're looking at numbers and interest
rates this is not a political site by
the way if you look at this right here
election days eight weeks away and a
massive expected maryland ballots could
prolong the wait for final result with
many states not beginning to count
absentee votes till the polls close
though polling average in
swing states currently give biden an
edge over president trump and he's held
a steady health
lead in national polls for most of the
year polls indicate right up until
election day in november tonight saying
that hillary clinton would would have
beat
uh trump so you see something like this
here for some of you guys that are
listening to this
i mean the one question you have to ask
when you're sitting down with your
accountant today is
what am i looking at with trump getting
elected what am i looking at with
biden getting elected i mean every the
first thing i do is i send an email i
said listen send me a breakdown
i need to know both of these things here
what does biden look like what does
trump look like everybody listening to
this should be doing this whether you're
making 60 grand
or millionaire what are your thoughts
about this account here okay are people
going to change who they're going to
vote for because
of that you think they might especially
rich people especially people in
silicon valley i mean are they still
anti-trump
but knowing you know what a difference
it's going to make in their finances you
know when i was researching this story
you know raising taxes is all about
generating revenue for the country you
know where they're missing out
tax collection um i saw this that the
irs
audited 1.73 million returns almost
one percent of all returns in 2010 but
they've had they've had to let go a lot
of
irs employees so they're auditing far
far fewer tax returns
um 770 000 so a million fewer
taxes tax returns were audited in 2019.
what uh obama's former campaign advisor
lawrence summers said if they went back
to the previous levels
they would generate 535 billion dollars
in tax revenue
if they were audit more people which is
kind of scary isn't it let's not give
the irs any more incentive here but
it's it's that that i find really
interesting um
people do have big decisions to make
when it comes to this what
do they lean one way or another when you
ask them when you when you send that
email or is it all data for them
well i asked adam the same question adam
said uh she says
if i was selling a company i'd probably
vote for trump but i'm not
so meaning how many people are going
through that process right now i mean
how big is that community really that's
going to want to make the difference how
many people are selling shares right now
how many people are
selling founders shares right now what's
a lot is it
10 million or is it 500 000 you know
is it uh a million that that's the
number that you look at and how many of
those are
really willing to flip to go to the
other side are they willing to flip and
vote for trump
are they willing to and you know what's
half the battle why people don't want to
vote for trump or biden you know what it
is
if you what is it if somebody asks if
somebody
it's if somebody asks adam in miami
who'd you vote for
he can't say trump
[Music]
you